c'est un sujet qui est très important
effectivement et ça parle tellement bien
et c'est tellement généreux c'est vrai
que tu as pas l'ouverture de tes
addictions de l'époque je fais combien
de temps que tu as arrêté de boire là
depuis le 18 octobre je tiens bien le
coup et je ne souffre pas et mon conseil
à tout le monde tous ceux qui veulent se
libérer que ça soit du vin ou du pétard
ou de la cocaïne de quoi que ce soit le
mieux c'est zéro d'un coup point ça
c'est à dire ben c'est-à-dire que ton
cerveau n'a plus à se poser les
questions ça existe pas de dire je fais
un coup de temps en temps je vais aller
je bois de misère de rouge le soir
c'est trop et 12 c'est pas assez et il a
résumé exactement la situation c'est à
dire c'est zéro tout le monde n'a pas ta
force la chanteuse rose pardon elle
était malade aujourd'hui elle devait
être là avec nous au téléphone m'a dit
hier par exemple pour la cocaïne on ne
s'en sort pas tout seul il faut demander
de l'aide donc peut-être que tout le
monde n'a pas ta force aussi c'est
possible ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'effectivement tu as reconnu dans les
interviews que tu étais monté jusqu'à 4
5 bouteilles d'alcool de de vin par jour
par jour qui avait eu les soirées
cocaïne les soirées machin et ben c'est
d'ailleurs il y a une période où il y
avait plus personne ne tu sortais le
soir après 4h du matin avec la mâchoire
comme ça en disant c'est où l'after et
toi et puis tu te couchais vers 14h
c'était une période mais qui il y a 25
ans maintenant pour moi il y a vraiment
avec du recul vous vous dites quoi oui
j'étais j'étais toxicoman et alcoolique
il y a il y a un truc qu'il faut quand
même un peu préciser c'est-à-dire que la
cocaïne c'est c'est pas une comment
c'est pas une dépendance physique
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas tu es pas
comme un héroïne Man en disant si j'ai
pas ma dose l'héroïne c'est terrifiant
parce que tu ne peux pas survivre sans
donc tu étais prêt à tout quoi il faut
aussi pour une période de plaisir très
courte et après tu n'es plus que
dépendant et pour être que normal et
c'est ce qu'il faut dire et c'est pour
ça que la chanteuse rose pardon je la
fais parler parce que j'ai eu un
interview disait que elle m'a dit à la
fin même pour passer l'aspirateur tu as
besoin de prendre de la cocaïne sinon tu
te tu tu tu passes pas l'aspirateur au
début tu fais avec le nez puis après
pour les grosses quantités tu prends
l'aspiration
si Tao comme ça de Queen chez toi
évidemment c'est mieux d'avoir du
matériel ce qui est important
le sujet est important ce que je veux
dire quand même c'est que Rose dit je
n'ai aucune je n'ai aucune excuse mon
enfant c'était la maison du bonheur vous
Jean-Marie c'est la classe qui démarre
je me souviens de vous raconter qu'avec
banal vous prenez des scooters et la
nuit vous regardez si les gens vous
reconnaissez tout ça en fait c'est quoi
c'est pour le dire aux gens au début
c'est festif et après c'est triste
extrêmement festive c'est-à-dire au
début au début au début c'est à dire tu
es un peu trop bourré ben tout d'un coup
tu es plus bourré et c'est ça le
problème et c'est notamment le piège
dans lequel Pierre est tombé bon c'est
tous bien amusés en sachant que tu as
des gens qui s'amusent en se disant je
n'ai rien à faire demain donc je m'amuse
et puis après je prends un lexomil et
puis je dors et demain sera une autre
bonne journée puis celui qui continue
quoi ouais donc
pierre était plutôt dans la deuxième
catégorie ma question c'est est-ce que
après là aussi je sais parler la
chanteuse rose pardon mais elle devait
être là elle dit après ben les concerts
ben tout d'un coup pour un concert je
buvais un petit peu pour un concert je
prenne un petit peu de cocaïne
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait par contre c'est
jamais moi je pourrai le travail jamais
jamais que pour le plaisir à quel moment
dans dans votre tête il y a un déclic du
ça y est en fait c'est c'est plus drôle
quoi il faut à quel moment il y a un
déclic de ah non mais c'est au jour par
jour c'est-à-dire comme je te le dis
avant de de se frotter à ce genre de
truc tu tu calibres déjà ta journée de
demain tu as rien demain non j'irai quel
moment tu t'es dit il faut arrêter non
mais je veux dire que c'est déjà un
premier moment ce que je suis en train
de dire c'est le premier moment c'est de
dire jamais jamais pour travailler
jamais si le lendemain tu pars pas comme
ça un rendez-vous tu es obligé de te
lever à 7 le lendemain là la veille
c'est pas vrai si tu y vas la veille
c'est déjà que tu es mort d'accord c'est
déjà que tu es foutu c'est déjà que tu
t'es rendu pièce et poignée aux produits
en question c'est trop facile c'est une
friandise qui te permet de faire plus de
pas être bourré tout en picolant donc
c'est un ça a été très facile pour
énormément de gens dans dans le métier
quoi mais même moi de la génération
d'avant moi il y avait j'ai eu des je
vais pas citer non bien sûr des
réalisateurs ou des ou d'autres mais bon
on pouvait se croiser aussi bien avec
Johnny Hallyday qui avait que d'autres
stars d'avant voilà c'était un petit peu
le la presque la rigolade on était dans
un endroit par exemple dans une boîte et
on voyait passer trois fois des filles
aller aux toilettes et puis on disait
ben il y a deux solutions ou elles ont
une cystite
ou elles ont de la cocaïne tu vois c'est
pas possible d'aller tant de fois mais
c'est vrai que tu racontes tellement
bien et tu as un tel sens du du chaud
mais aussi aux gens que j'ai expliqué
aux gens aussi et ils disent tous que du
Festif très vite ça passe à un état
dépressif il y a des gens qui se
suicident il y a des gens qui parlent
leur carrière c'est très dangereux
physiquement ça crée des AVC enfin
regardez pas de mal c'est c'était festif
Palma de 20 ans il faisait l'Olympia
aujourd'hui il a presque tué des gens il
est dans un hôpital faut quand même
rappeler les choses Julien est-ce que
moi j'ai pas touché à ça est-ce que
est-ce que sont très honnêtes j'ai fait
beaucoup de télé et on a le sentiment
qu'en ce moment quand on parle de
cocaïne on voit tout le monde les
animateurs presque dire alors c'est
c'est comment comment vous dites Sho
Shine qu'est-ce qui se passe
les gens découvrent découvrent ce truc
je vois les journalistes poser des
questions qu'est-ce que c'est exactement
la vérité la télévision vous en avez vu
oh non moi j'avais bon non jamais jamais
mais dont je sais pas ce que c'est
jamais entendu parler
comment ça se prend à qui on achète
comment tu vas pas
un extrait c'est très important pour moi
parce que j'aimerais redire aux gens
aussi qu'on est pas normal quand on
prend ce produit et j'en ai pour preuve
vous Jean-Marie depuis que vous êtes
dans TPMP j'ai mais vraiment j'ai un mec
intelligent brillant doué et qui a du
riz ah vous avez pas fait le Stade de
France pour rien vous avez le générosité
incroyable et je me souviens de l'année
dernière où c'était ça
te va lui décideur mais peut-être que je
n'ai rien à voir sur 100 millions mais
c'est eux
qui je te parle décideurs quand un homme
politique vient te dire que le conseil
scientifique
a décidé que toi tu dis [__] c'est pas
rien c'est pas trois personnes c'est une
majorité des gens qui décident ces
gens-là sont aux ordres ils sont aux
ordres du pognon Jean-Marie vous avez
une rage incroyable voilà alors la
journaliste qui s'appelle Déborah a été
internée
de vie
on parle sérieusement et cache là juste
ce personnage là
tu m'as fait rire comme toi j'ai
découvert un jean un Bigard différent
depuis trois ans un billard qui gueule
comme ça très belle
je veux dire il est oublié ce personnage
c'était quoi l'époque qu'est-ce qui
c'était l'alcool c'était déjà dit
c'est des trucs qui m'énervent je
m'énerve c'est vrai je suis un peu à
fleur de peau je le reconnais et
maintenant mon prochain spectacle
s'appelle j'arrête les conneries et je
vais être cool je vais juste parler
doucement et je vais m'exprimer
patiemment je vais je vais recueillir
parfois des insultes des trucs qui avant
me mettaient en colère ne me met plus en
colère maintenant
je par exemple ce que tu viens de
montrer là j'étais pas sous l'emprise
[Musique]
c'est que je n'ai plus de colère je n'ai
plus physiquement tu as changé
c'est-à-dire le talent est resté mais
pardon ça change juste tout quoi est-ce
que je peux bouger ma femme m'a
énormément aidé et on a vraiment est-ce
que je peux poser une question
[Musique]
les médias pour pour parler et j'avais
déjà dit tout ce que j'avais à dire
d'accord encore cet après-midi et avant
ce d'enregistrer cette émission il y a
encore des gens qui m'ont appelé de BFM
pour me dire on fait un reportage de 45
minutes sur pierre Palma on aimerait
bien que que tu parles et je lui ai
répondu très gentiment désolé mais je ne
vais pas faire ça tout ce que j'avais à
dire je l'ai dit ça m'a aussi un petit
peu
brûlé la gorge tu vois parce que tu es
bien obligé d'intervenir sans intervenir
c'est un moment extrêmement délicat il y
a certainement une belle prise de
position j'ai j'ai tellement de peine
j'ai de la peine d'avoir de la peine
mais en tout cas ça me remue ça veut
depuis le début cette affaire je
m'endors avec ça je me réveille avec ça
parce que j'ai été trop proche de pierre
et que cette cette chute dans le vide
qu'on de l'extérieur tu vois un pote qui
tombe où tu peux rien faire et si tu
peux rien faire
est-ce que vous pensez que parce que un
être lambda il fait de la prison il paye
sa peine et il en sort et il reprend son
métier est-ce que vous pensez qu'un
Palmade peut-être après rédemption est
prison si à présent je ne connais rien
de tout ça il peut il peut reprendre une
carrière un certain temps franchement
après un certain temps non je peux pas
m'expliquer je connais pas assez mais
c'est pas pour le connaître moi je peux
pas dire ça j'en sais rien je pose la
question différemment vous êtes
quelqu'un du public vous aimez ce qu'il
fait
c'est pas question vous allez le voir
s'il fait un spectacle ou pas
une fois qu'il a été jugé il a fait sa
peine bien sûr
mais moi je réponds j'y vais pas mais
vous vous répondez je n'ai aucun
jugement
j'y vais pas Palmade c'est un peu tôt
encore enfin c'est tellement frère
c'était pas une question en fait ce que
je voulais dire simplement c'est que
quand on voit elle en parle très bien
d'ailleurs rose bon c'est pas là
aujourd'hui mais qui a un podcast qui
est fantastique sur les sur les
addictions elle parle aussi de la
descente enfin voilà parce que on parle
du côté festif effectivement mais on
cherche toujours quoi l'effet du premier
trait qu'on retrouve jamais en fait donc
on prend un trait c'est super c'est
festif c'est génial on se prend pour la
reine du pétrole le deuxième le
troisième etc on n'a jamais ce même
effet donc c'est ça l'escalade et elle
parle très bien des moments de descente
et sur les humeurs aussi ça joue
énormément
la première c'est on dit est-ce que les
people doivent en parler mais c'est vrai
pas que une fois que tu en parles on va
être honnête quel producteur te produit
quel assureur t'assure qu'elle fasse tu
mets ta carrière en danger donc c'est
très compliqué donc on comprend qu'ils
ont prépa et puis autre question c'est
tu as des enfants oui est-ce que tu as
peur qui tombe là dedans qu'est-ce que
tu leur dis est-ce que tu non je suis
quasiment sur certains que ça ne sera
pas le cas parce que d'abord tout ça est
très antérieur à
ma paternité tu vois que ce soit mon
premier enfant que j'ai eu de ma
première femme où les deux que j'ai eu
de Lola
non je ne pense pas une seconde que ça
leur arrivera parce que comme je connais
le véhicule c'est si j'ose dire je serai
en veille en permanence je guetterai
chaque moment chaque truc ça sera
difficile de passer au travers de du
film tu les verras tu vois bien sûr donc
moi je verrai tu vois les mais c'est
très important parce que pardon non s'il
avait peur de
c'est pas ça mais non avis non non je ne
crois pas même si la majorité des gens
dans le monde pensent que ça n'est pas
possible même si Jésus lui-même disait
au voleur tu ne voles je te pardonne et
tu ne veux pas tu seras plus jamais un
voleur mais Jésus lui dit déménage parce
que pour tout le monde tu seras toujours
un voleur même si ne tu ne voles plus
jamais de ta vie donc si tu veux de ce
point de vue là c'est très dur parce que
tu as une condamnation à perpète du
monde entier mais toi rien ne t'empêche
toi de dire pour moi c'est un truc mais
toi les gars à 31 décembre qu'est-ce que
tu fais tu bois de l'eau oui oui oui bah
là je te signale que entre le 28 octobre
et maintenant ouais il y a eu Noël il y
a eu le premier janvier et ah non je me
suis je m'en suis je me suis régalé de
m'abstenir avec les autres j'ai encore
eu un pote tout à l'heure au téléphone
j'ai dit quand est-ce qu'on se voit pour
pas boire
bah c'est la plus belle des conclusions
vraiment vraiment le danger de tout ça